[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
Jesus [ __ ] crazy it's only Tuesday
[Music]
it's got like mountains of news to talk
about
insanity
Ron DeSantis dresses up like a Dallas
Cowboys chillied Cheerleader we have
Herschel Walker and unsurprisingly
paying for abortions
uh Christian Walker turning on him which
is also not surprising
and Grandpa Poopypants apparently tried
to get his lawyer to lie and his lawyer
wouldn't do it
there's just so much news
one of the most significant things right
now happening right now currently as we
speak is Justice katanji Brown Jackson
who is highly qualified and earned her
spot on our court
is doing exactly what we the people
voted for
exactly using her Brilliance her
intelligence her knowledge of the law
her knowledge of History to absolutely
slam dunk
these right-wing talking points of
voting rights into the [ __ ] trash
I think a lot of people will miss this
today unfortunately because of [ __ ]
boxes like Ron DeSantis
Herschel Walker and Donald Trump but
here's the thing
is that not not here we can talk about
these sorts of things here on the Tony
Michaels podcast
we can discuss
why it is so important that we engage in
our democracy so that people who have
earned their spot
on our court
and they you know did she earned her
spot on all the courts she's been on but
specifically
her career has led to this moment where
she
is sitting on the Supreme Court of the
United States
and in that moment
in that moment Justice katanji Brown
Jackson
is delivering up her entire experience
the entirety of her education
the entirety of her career
and what should be
hundreds
of arguments
thousands of arguments
is the Hope
that Justice Brown Jackson will sit for
this morning she shows her Brilliance
and shows why she's qualified to ask
questions as a Supreme Court Justice
it's not I mean she's brilliant
absolutely [ __ ] brilliant Highly
Educated has a lot of experience on a
bench as a judge
but her experience in life
for these solicitors from Alabama to
tell her what it's like to be a black
woman I just don't think
I just don't think that many folks will
get it besides her having that
experience
and that's the most important part about
the court
they are making decisions that are going
to shape
not just your democracy but your
children's your grandchildren's our
future leaders
of this country they're they're going to
shape our democracy
and I know so many pro-democracy people
come here every day to hear
the cathartic yelling
and to and to get their little dose of
democratic politicization because that's
what we do here I do not give a [ __ ]
but to listen
to Judge Brown Jackson give her argument
on the 14th Amendment today and say no
the 14th Amendment wasn't written
as if racism didn't exist you [ __ ]
boneheads
now that's my way of putting it
but the absolute Brilliance of Justice
Jackson
Justice Brown Jackson
presenting her argument for why the 14th
Amendment
it's not a good argument to take away
rights
especially voting rights the entire
intention was to give Friedman
who were who were freed slaves
the rights that were granted to other
free man
white property owners in this country
and she sees it all through the eyes and
the experience
of a black woman
what a novel idea
this should not have taken this long
to get to this point
and we still have a lot of work to do
this is not the end this is just the
beginning
folks this is the beginning of what
our democracy's court should be
we are a long way away from that
because we know that the 2016 election
dumped huge consequences on our country
and our democracy future
because people would not engage
would not be disciplined in their
democracy
but we had a little more discipline in
2020 we understood the stakes
and I think we understand the stakes in
this midterm because this election
that we have now in front of us on
November 8th
is the most important election of our
democracies lifetime
and as soon as it's over as soon as it's
over the votes are counted they're
certified
and that new government is formed all
around the country
the next one will be the most important
because these people are not going to
stop they're not going to stop that if
you if you think they're gonna stop just
look at this Herschel Walker story
I'm gonna talk a lot after Herschel
Walker's story today
but I do not want this story
to overshadow what made
katanji Brown Jackson's judgeship
possible
our democracy
made that possible she earned the spot
with her experience and her education
and her career on the bench
but without us engaging in making the
right decisions being coherent
not playing to the dumpster fire
and politicizing things to win elections
that's a thing you gotta do in democracy
if you want to set policy is Win
elections that's what you have to do
it's a thing
oh well Tony You Can't Fight Fire with
Fire the [ __ ] you can't
you want to win
or do you want to just say well we we
gave it a good try we gave it a good try
and we didn't we didn't get down in the
mud with them I mean we lost and we're
definitely going to lose rights over it
and these fascists are going to take
over and strip us from our vote and our
democracy because that's what they're
doing on the Supreme Court are you
listening to me
this morning they're making arguments to
take away rights to vote
that's the argument that's the [ __ ]
argument before the court
to take away rights to vote
it's a serious issue
and the reality is that you have your
voice heard
or heard because you wouldn't speak
that's right either way you do this it
doesn't matter
rather you engage or don't engage that
voice is heard
this democracy will hear your voice
rather you yell and scream or you stay
silent
and in 2020 this country understood the
stakes
that we can't stay silent
we can't let these this [ __ ]
buffoonery go on
I do not believe
that 81 million people voted for Joe
Biden now when I say that people like oh
my God
there's a there's a hefty percentage of
that 81 million
that is okay with Biden they're okay
with him being president
they don't necessarily like him
maybe they don't like some of his
policies but they voted against Trump
because they understood the stakes in
our democracy they understood
what it means to be heard
brother you stay silent are you yelling
scream like I do every day in front of
this microphone you are being heard
and so many times we forget that inside
of our democracy
silence is deafening
so don't be silent
engage lean into the democracy
it's what will deliver you
equity and equality and I'll I'll tell
you that it's not perfect
it's [ __ ] difficult
it's difficult as hell
it's the hard thing to do which is
democracy that's the difficult part
of government
to compromise to come together to figure
out a way to make things work for the
majority
of the citizens and the people inside
the country
it's a difficult thing
it's not easy the easy week thing is to
hail one Messiah and make them the
leader
and make sure that anything they do and
say is the correct thing and the truth
and they can do no wrong to sound
familiar
that's the easy week thing to do
but we're doing it
we're doing it
and the truth the truth will be told
folks if if this Herschel Walker
Christian Locker story doesn't prove to
you that eventually eventually this damn
of lies that these that these [ __ ]
boneheads are trying to sell to America
that dam is going to break then you're
not paying attention
because that story about Herschel Walker
and Christian Walker
is on its face is absolutely [ __ ] a
circus
a circus but this is the circus that
they're gearing up to take to have to
have
the Republican Party
Jesus Christ you already have Ron
DeSantis he's and I said this
for days I said this he's going to fail
at this recovery in Florida he's going
to fail and the reason why is because he
is Ron DeSantis
I didn't need any more proof than that
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes
and [ __ ] boxes do [ __ ] box things that
is how it works
the one thing that Florida should have
never done is thought that Rhonda Santos
was qualified to be a governor of
Florida
the one thing the one thing that
disqualified Rhonda Santos more than
anything else other than he's a [ __ ]
fascist and a goddamn Nazi
and a thief and a crook oh you goddamn
right he's gonna steal some of this
money for sure 100 percent gonna steal
this [ __ ] money him and his wife have
already got Charities they're gonna
they're gonna do something I really
geared up he might lose this election
they're gonna need they're gonna need a
new [ __ ] third or fourth house
whatever the hell they're gonna need a
yacht whatever the hell they need
they're gonna try to get it
they're [ __ ] they're [ __ ] out of
their minds
but the one thing the one thing that
should have disqualified him in any
primary
no matter the party Republican party the
America First Nazi party whatever
was that that [ __ ] voted against
hurricane relief for Sandy
voted against it
he was going to be the governor of
Florida
it's not a matter of if
are it's just win win and how bad will
it be and the [ __ ] is walking
around in pristine clean light boots
acting like he's helping clean up
it looks [ __ ] weird number one then
he has boots on it almost seems like
someone [ __ ] trapped this son of a
[ __ ]
into this picture they set him up
but the thing that gets me the most
about the white boots is ridiculous as
it looks I don't know even know who the
[ __ ] buys white rubber boots what in the
[ __ ] the only time I've ever seen any
kind of rubber boots at all they're
[ __ ] black or camouflage this is
[ __ ] weird to begin with
but they don't even have a speck of dirt
on them
not a speck of dirt and he looks like
he's doing something special and he's oh
yeah he's he's rubbing elbows with the
law enforcement in an area that has a
few down limbs
he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about you not one [ __ ]
and you say well what does this have to
do with the Herschel Walker story
it has a lot to do with it Christian
Walker goat takes to social media today
and I actually I reached out to
Christian in his DMs I said Christian
come on the show
I'm I'm I don't agree with anything you
say
I am I don't I I I cannot figure out
any one thing that I would probably
agree with him on
and I told him it would be
straightforward and I would ask some
really tough questions but come on the
show I reached out to him
because he's freaking out on social
media this morning talking about lies
lies lies lies he's on his social media
supporting Ron DeSantis folks give me a
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here with that
nonsense anyone who's simping for
Christian Walker today because oh well
he's just he's just telling the truth
Moment of clarity get the [ __ ] out of
here [ __ ] you he's been lying and he's
admitting it now this is a great off
ramp
and it may be a great model for trumpism
this might be the moment that people can
go well maybe this is how it's done
because I think the country is going to
take Christian and his word here and go
well you know the whole
tired of the lies thing that's worth
excusing him on whatever
fine fine by me
if it causes him to torch herschel's
campaign
and make sure to put Warnock over the
top which Warnock was going to win that
race folks I hahaha
the the best part about and and the
person who is [ __ ] [ __ ] their
britches this morning in Georgia
is Kemp
it's Kemp because if Herschel Walker
suppresses that vote by God we're going
to have a damn good Governor down in
Georgia
folks those [ __ ] seats matter
you just look at this [ __ ] case that
Alabama's bringing to the Supreme Court
trying to take away your goddamn vote
these governorships [ __ ] matter
what's happening in Texas where the
governor of Texas is using [ __ ]
taxpayer dollars like the governor in
Florida
as campaign [ __ ] stunts
Texas Paul is going to be on this
morning he's going to tell us about a
warden
Trump isn't through and through too baby
racism bigotry
the same way the same [ __ ] and how
they treat those migrants from Venezuela
and Rhonda Santa shipped them to
Martha's Vineyard from Texas which
doesn't make any sense but that's just
the way bigots work it's bigotry is not
supposed to make much sense folks
the same way Greg Abbott and this Warden
did in Texas Texas Paul is going to
break it down for us today
but better wins in Texas
folks
that's a huge win for your Liberty
because Beto is willing just he's even
he's willing just to go and talk to you
regardless
if you're a Democrat or Republican if
you're a better supporter or a trump
supporter
that's why he's winning
that's why he's [ __ ] winning
these races matter these governorships
matter yes we have to win the Senate
absolutely we have to lean into the
house and win every [ __ ] one of those
seats we possibly can win it is
crucially important to our democracy but
just as important are these Governor's
races
and we have to pile mountains of votes
on top of these [ __ ] because
it's not just a matter of winning at
this point
it's not just a matter of winning we
have to send the message
not just to us not just to the
Republicans but to the entire world
that look this trumpism [ __ ] is not us
it is the few Among Us that still want
to participate in this fascist nonsense
this buffoonery these this this swamp of
Lies
and maybe just maybe we'll give an
off-ramp and Christian Walker the way
that he's handling his father's campaign
is a good model for that whatever fine
I'm okay with it
I'm okay with these people coming out
saying okay yeah we relying the whole
time it's all [ __ ] we get it you
know you know it was all [ __ ] show it
was all a show
and we get it now we'll get back to
business now we'll pay attention to the
things that [ __ ] matter instead of
people's genitalia and who they love and
books at Book Fairs
nonsense just [ __ ] absolute nonsense
when we got real [ __ ] to deal with
in our democracy
I want to take away [ __ ] rights I
don't think so and that's what they're
doing this morning in the Supreme Court
folks
yes I want to talk about the Herschel
Walker story yes I want to talk about
the Christian Walker video and we're
going to
you goddamn right I'm gonna frame this
up the way that needs to be framed up so
you can go out there and spread the
message you goddamn right I'm going to
that's my whole goal and purpose every
single day to sit in front of this
microphone for two hours a day
I don't just sit here and yell and
scream into this thing
for the heck of it well sometimes
but there's a goal in mind the goal in
mind is for you guys to have your
messaging
and go out and pound the airwaves knock
the doors write them write the postcards
the letters make the phone calls the
text messages for these campaigns
but more than anything engage with your
community
that is the most important part of all
of this
and you have to lean into it you can't
just say well Herschel Walker well he's
done so we don't have to worry about
George anymore [ __ ] that [ __ ]
Now's the Time to really lean in
Now's the Time to really lean into this
when you're watching your lives be
exposed and the Liars themselves are
going I can't stand the lies anymore
can't take it Now's the Time to lean in
baby
lean into that [ __ ] let's let's
get Warnock reelected and let's put
Stacy Abrams as the governor of Georgia
let's do that [ __ ] them
now is not the time to give up now is
not the time to focus our energy
somewhere else now is the time to lean
into every single one of these
[ __ ]
you want to stop out trumpism
it's you that's gonna do it it's you
no one else is gonna do this
these these ballots aren't gonna aren't
gonna Mark themselves
your friends your family your
communities ballots aren't going to Mark
themselves it has to be done by you with
the messaging and the enthusiasm
and the absoluteless Relentless attitude
For Your Love of democracy
because that's what they're terrified of
and again I'll say it again and again
and again that's what they're trying to
do in the Supreme Court today is take
away your right to engage in your
democracy so you better [ __ ] vote
before they take the right away from you
use it or lose it think of it that way
and let's elect pro-democracy candidates
who are interested
in policy
advancing people's rights not
suppressing people's rights the freedom
to oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty
got it
every day that's the first thing this
show says
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people
is not
Liberty
and yesterday I told you I'd have
something special for you
and I just didn't get to it so let's get
to it right now speaking of that saying
here is a new piece of merch
store.dtonymichaels.com wear it loudly
and proudly
this is the message that you carry with
you everywhere
you deliver this to your community
to your family your friends your
colleagues the people in the PTA
this is one of the only pieces of merch
that probably isn't going to say the
word [ __ ] on it
by the way
no vulgarity even on this piece of merch
but as much as the t-shirts and Portion
important and it is it's the message
that is the most important
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty
and that's what Justice Brown Jackson
did this morning
she showed us if we work hard in our
democracy and we do the things we're
supposed to do
just like she earned and did the thing
she was supposed to do to earn that spot
this morning to deliver up what the
actual 14th Amendment and the history
behind it is
to undo these conservatives argue
basically she was using the conservative
originalist argument to undermine the
conservatives originalist argument of
why to take away the right to vote
brilliant
absolutely 100 brilliant
and I'm not saying that she knows my
message or my phrase
but we don't have to all know
to know that that is the case
not everyone has to have oh well Tony
Michael said that doesn't matter you
don't need to know that
just need the message that's all you
need
I'm glad you joined me every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
full hours right here on YouTube Twitter
and twitch and simulcasting from
Facebook if you're on Facebook we
simulcast on two Facebook pages the
Midas touch page and my page so go
follow us on Facebook
if you haven't already if you're on the
books of face I know some people have
you know canceled their account over
there but if you still have account over
there do me a favor go over to the Tony
Michaels follow me there we broadcast
live from there we also broadcast live
on Twitter at Tony Michael's spot don't
forget to follow us there
come subscribe on the YouTubes tubes of
you get over here and get your
subscription here it's free I know it
sounds subscription sounds like there's
like a payment or something right
I wish YouTube would change that to
where it's a follow not a subscribe
because it doesn't cost you anything
it's all free everything's free it's
free to listen to my [ __ ] yelling and
screaming two hours a day every single
day but I'll tell you what we run on
your support even though the show is
free we run on your support
we run on it here so if you'd like to
help us out monetarily if you're not
buying merch which I know you are go to
Tony Michaels dot live slash tip you can
give a one-time tip or you can do it
monthly you can set it up to where you
don't have to you can just forget about
it everyone it's a dollar two dollars
five dollar whatever you want
we appreciate all the support because
it's not just about the money that you
give in the tip jar
it's about being here every day
listening to this message and go
spreading the message I know I'm not
going to get rich off this
no hell in way
but I know I can advance democracy lean
into it a little bit
I know I got the gift of yelling and
screaming in a cathartic way
and I try to serve it up every single
weekday for you
so please
stay tuned don't go anywhere because you
know it's Tuesday and Tuesdays are
special days here on the Tony Michaels
podcast of course it's Taco Tuesday but
it's Texas Paul Tuesday
and boy do we have some stuff from Texas
ball that he wants to share with you the
Tony Michaels podcast audience today so
stick around don't go anywhere
Texas Paul right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum [ __ ] them we're
to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for sticking around through the break
as promised
you don't [ __ ] around here we're gonna
deliver
[Music]
the mind is mighty favorite
Texas Paul is joining us Texas Paul how
are you this morning
oh man I'm I am sad brother I am sad
what's going on over there
you know it's looking more and more like
South Texas you know when you you know
it Texas is different we're just
different people here we we have this
sense of pride in our state that's just
like no other I mean it is like no
weather I mean I get I get family
members that come down here and they're
like what the hell is with all the flags
man and I'm like that's just Texas man
we're just proud they're like what are
you proud of and be in Texas you know
and everything I looked at today for
today's preparation just South Texas is
turning into South Africa apartheid
South Africa it's just
the the last few weeks of stories I've
done have just broken my heart I mean
they're just
I tell you Tony you and I got to clean
up our own backyard
we really do I mean I don't know what is
wrong
with the white guys these days but uh
yeah we got we gotta we've got to clean
up so I learned something new today I
never wanted to learn in my life you
know what uh
immigration calls
uh
this item Seekers migrants hmm
Tonks
do what
Tonks have you ever heard have you heard
this Gabe Sanchez have you heard this
before
dunks
Tonks t-o-n-c Tonk you know what that is
no no that's a sound that's the sound a
human head makes when you hit it with
one of these flashlights oh Jesus
that is what Customs and Border Patrol
agents after they graduate from the
the academy in Glenn County Georgia and
head down to South Texas the senior
agents teach them to refer to uh
migrants as Tonks
um
and it's just that whole culture that's
leading to what we're talking about
today you know we just had a warden of
the West Texas Detention Center down in
Sierra Blanca you know have you ever
heard of Fort Stockton Texas you know
Billy the Kid that whole story I I know
I know the Billy the Kid story but the
the name Fort Stockton escapes me he
would he would often cross into Mexico
through Fort Stockton he would because
you know most of his his
activities were in New Mexico and he
would cut through to Texas just
get you know to cross into Mexico
um you know through the Chihuahuan
Desert and Fort Stockton was just uh
friendly to him so he used it a lot well
Sierra Blanca is a little town just
outside Fort Stockton
and that's where the West Jackson
Detention Center is the used to be an
ice facility and they now this is
privately owned this is a privately
owned facility yeah owned by a company
called LaSalle okay they had a contract
with ice and Ice revoked that contract
late in 2019.
um but this guy remained on as the
warden of that facility
and he is the guy that was driving down
the highway
uh last week and saw a group of
immigrants
uh jumped out of his pickup truck and
there were 13 of them 11 of them went
and hid behind a water tower and two of
them hid behind a bush right and
according to testimony from all the
witnesses he told the immigrants in
Spanish he said come out here you little
[ __ ] come on you little asses
in Spanish He yells at him and they
didn't come out uh so he popped Two
Shots into the bushes they were hiding
he hit man in the head and killed him
and shot a woman in the stomach Jesus
Christ now this is this is the one
because he's with his twin brother right
is that right Mike we saw their their
pictures on social media and it kind of
got buried underneath other stories
right right the hurricane they got
buried underneath the hurricane
so uh Mike Shepard is the is the warden
of the West Texas Detention Center at
the time
um and his brother Mark you know yells
at him did you get him
and uh they hop back in their pickup
truck and they just leave them the first
squirrel or something Jesus Christ they
just leave them for dead didn't they
tried to say because when the
investigation happened when everybody
else carried the woman you know the
woman survived she's in an El Paso
hospital
um
you know everybody gave testimony they
went back and looked at camera footage
to see what truck fit the description
they were able to pick the brothers up
they said oh we were out hunting grouse
and uh we we were shooting at grouse
and I said really uh can we see your
shotgun okay why does it have Buckshot
in it if you're hunting breasts oh did I
say Grouse I meant we were hunting
Javelin we saw javelina Hogs is what we
saw
so the prosecutor
um
and I'll give him credit for this he
didn't charge him with murder he didn't
charge him with murder he charged them
uh with manslaughter
and the reason for that why do you give
them yeah why do you give them credit is
that is that because you think that this
is going to stick to them more than the
murder charges
yeah this is there's no way to lose this
right no matter what if you fire into a
bush
and you shoot a human being you're
guilty of manslaughter
because you shot a deadly weapon
at a Target that you couldn't identify
knowing that there's human beings in
that bush
yeah well he he's claiming he didn't
know that but it's Irrelevant in the
manslaughter charge because you didn't
identify your Target and you fired
anyways
it doesn't matter what you thought you
saw in in a manslaughter okay that's why
I'm giving that that attorney props he's
going to take a lot of heat a lot of
people are going to want murder charges
and he's going to take a lot of heat for
it but he is a smart prosecutor he is
he's going to get them on manslaughter
and hopefully the judge will will you
know maximize the sentence which will
which would be a normal murder
conviction anyways
um you mean you mean in Texas if the if
the judge wants to sentence him to the
maximum amount it would be almost the
same as what a murder charge
um first conviction for murder yeah
right right like if they got him for
murder two you know they're not going to
usually give a maximum sentence out
although there is depraved indifference
in this one I mean it's it's it's a
horrible horrific story
but it gets worse guys I mean it gets
worse I mean
um this guy back in 2018 they had a
report on his prison and they had some
somalis that were held there
and uh they pepper sprayed these somalis
so bad that they were coughing up blood
they'd beat them
horribly uh sexually assaulted them
made a habit of grabbing them by the
pardon the expression but grabbing them
by the dick and pulling them around
um
the warden himself took part in this the
the uh there's the same guy that shot
into the bush right yeah the warden
himself took part in this he he uh you
know would often oversee these abuses uh
and imagine being in in solitary
confinement how small that cell is and
just getting soaked with pepper spray so
bad that you can't stop coughing until
you're coughing up blood
you know and one of these guys I was
reading the actual report it's a long
report but it was worth the read one of
these guys the reason he was there was I
mean he was married to an American
they'd been living here forever he
thought he was naturalized to be quite
honest he may still have a case but he
doesn't want doesn't want to come back
um
his parents were naturalized he can't
remember if he was 17 or 18. if he was
17 when his parents naturalized he was
naturalized he became a citizen if he
was 18 then he's got to go through the
naturalization process himself
but he's not even going to fight that
because he does not want to come back to
America he does not this guy the warden
punched because he asked for underwear
and socks because they were not giving
them clothes to change into I mean they
were just the same clothes forever
they were washing them in the toilet and
[ __ ] like that trying to yeah he said
can I get a pair of underwear and socks
the warden
punched him in the face four times
and uh
the the guy said because there was a
medical staff there attending to
somebody said she said you're going to
let him do this don't you see this the
guy the medical officer turned around
and says I didn't see anything
I didn't see anything
so when he's in in confinement the
warden came for a visit and while he was
handcuffed to the ground just started
kicking the [ __ ] out of him in his ribs
till he was coughing up blood
and that's that's that's this Prince
that murdered these migrants
the worst part is he stayed in his job
this report went to a federal prosecutor
in West Texas the federal prosecutor
took a look at it and said okay some of
this was done in front of ice agents
uh we we we need to run this up the
ladder and it ran up to the AG and doj
and died
who is the AG at the time
Jeff sessions hmm
one Jeff sessions the one that went down
to the border and denigrated people
coming here and seeking Refuge I seem to
remember that yeah yep that's where all
the abuses and everything started the
separating the kids and all that stuff
and you know ice was out of control
think about this guy
the reason his story is important was he
was busted in 2013 for having a little
grass I don't mean distribution weight I
mean he had some grass
right
so they said we're going to deport you
well they couldn't if you remember at
the time in Somalia there was a war
going on right that went on for like a
decade but so they said well we can't
Deport you you just report to ice every
year and and live your life go on we'll
worry about you later of course when
Trump came into office he's like send
them all out get rid of all of them so
he goes to check in and and
they arrest him right there in front of
his family
send them to the West Texas Detention
Center where all this happened
so anyways they deported him he
converted to Christianity
and that's a No-No in Somalia
um I don't remember know if you remember
Black Hawk Down and all the Warlords and
all everything that was going on in
Somalia and Mogadishu all of that that I
mean
um they deported every one of these
somalis back to the middle of that war
zone
several of them were here seeking Asylum
because they had spoken out
against
these abuses in Somalia we use them for
their their their
stories and then we deported them under
Trump
I mean it's just it's got me so down
guys I just this is not my Texas this is
not my people you know and I just
I just man I'm I I'm I'm
enraging inside I'm just raging inside
because
you know I grew up in South Texas I did
and this is not
you know man growing up in South Texas
is like growing up in L.A you know I
mean it's just we're all
there these divides aren't there until
you get these [ __ ] wackadoodles
and I'm telling you Tony that's why
we've got to clean up our backyard man
we really do I don't know what the [ __ ]
is wrong with with white people these
days man and I'm just gonna say it man
white guys [ __ ] suck right now
um
you know I had a conversation just
last Sunday with the with the guy blew
his mind His Name Was Daryl he's like
you should we were having a discussion
on what to do going forward and I was
telling well we need more engagement we
need to be together you know because I
know I grew up in an environment where
there was no you know difference it
didn't matter what color you were we
were all together you know because we we
were at each other's homes and and you
know I mean hell [ __ ]
you know they called me Gordo forever
you know what I mean that was my
nickname for the longest time you know
look at look at caveman he knows what
Gordo means the pinche Flacco but
[Laughter]
but you grow up together and you don't
have that Hate in Your Heart man and he
said yeah but all white people are
racist
he said admit it and I said well yeah
we all are
we grow up segregated for the first part
of our lives and we grew up racist
because there's the other that's that's
human nature it's programmed into us we
we look at somebody who's different
and we immediately this is our tribe and
that's your tribe we're fight or flight
program for it and to claim that we're
not is a lie it's a lie and
the cure for that is to
spend time together
so that when I look at somebody I'm not
seeing the other
that's just my brother
you know that's how I become My
Brother's Keeper you know I mean I say
it all the time and my we are the am I
My Brother's Keeper party because we
spend time with each other we we love
each other man we're human beings you
know I want us good for for everybody as
I do for myself but these [ __ ]
Republican rightening [ __ ] man
you know people like Jeff sessions who
grew up in [ __ ] Alabama segregated
himself his whole goddamn life this and
the other creates a policy in my [ __ ]
state
that creates this culture with ice and
Border Patrol and everybody and you know
I I don't blame
all border patrol agents because they go
in when these but border patrol agents
go in
man it's like I was I was reading a
report from Human Rights Watch that was
talking about how broken our border
patrol is
you know these guys are working with
[ __ ] militias man racist militias
down here
and border patrol agents are like buddy
buddy with them
these new Agents come in and they're
good people they're they're they want to
do the right thing but you put them into
this broken [ __ ] culture
and within five or six years you've got
another [ __ ] broken agent you do yeah
I mean
I don't know what to tell you man I mean
other than kicking ass and taking names
I don't know what to do about this
problem man I really don't I mean to fix
it we all have to cut this [ __ ] out but
to cut the [ __ ] out we're gonna have to
put our boots on the [ __ ] necks of
these [ __ ] Republicans with this
goddamn culture this division [ __ ]
they're always trying to sow I mean
every goddamn election look what
Abbott's doing down here it's an
invasion it's an invade [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what you know why
they're saying that you want to really
know why they're saying that give it to
me guns guns it all boils down to
[ __ ] guns again because we sell a
[ __ ] ton of guns going the other way
across the goddamn border so they want
you to focus remember they're always
saying accuse your enemy
they get it from Joseph [ __ ] gerbils
the Nazi accuse your enemy of what
you're guilty of so they accuse them of
smuggling they accuse them of being
dangerous they accuse them of being
violent well we're the [ __ ] dangerous
and violent ones we're exporting our
[ __ ] guns every major Clash that the
Mexican government has had with cartels
down there they pick up off the dead
American [ __ ] guns
American [ __ ] guns these guns aren't
made in Mexico man they're not shipped
in through Mexico they're shipped in
through the Texas [ __ ] border
and that's the problem
yeah sure there are drugs coming north
but 85 percent of the [ __ ] fentanyl
they're claimed they're bitching about
is brought in by Americans
Cato Institute I don't agree with a
[ __ ] conclusion that the Cato
incident comes up with because they're
libertarian
they're libertarian and I've never
agreed with Libertarians
but their facts are never wrong
they don't lie
now what they
deduce from those facts I disagree with
but they don't lie about their facts
right because what you're saying is
they're like oh there's this many pounds
of fentanyl coming across the border so
that's why this group is failing like
well that's not you're you're twisting
the fact you're using the facts
when you see tweets of of people uh that
literally say this was seized you're you
have to stop and say do you know what
the word means do you know like just by
by you Tweeting that They seized this
many pounds hundreds of pounds of
whatever the drug is you then have to
stop and say do you understand what the
actual definition of seas means like
you're not you're not completely grat
like getting what you're what you're
tweeting out right now which is they're
doing their job and you're criticizing
them for doing their job but saying that
they're not doing their job so but you
see it all the time I mean you you know
you you just mentioned like the
projection you know you like Joseph
gorbel's like you wanna you wanna blame
others for the very thing you're guilty
of and whether it's an abortion whether
it's trafficking humans whether it's uh
uh deaths by gun whatever it might be
these are all things that the Republican
party is guilty of and will project onto
anyone else to justify
the act that they can then do which is
to buy more guns or to enforce more
policies or restrict restrict more
rights or whatever it might be
it's them obviously to control like we
know that it works
and we've seen it before
and we've talked about on the show like
fascism you know isn't new and it's not
inventive and it's it it regurgitates
the same types of things that they do
again and again so that's why it's like
oh we know exactly what it is in a
Playbook they're trying to do because
we've literally seen it before on
multiple occasions
um they they don't reinvent the wheel
here they're still the same fascist
regime that wants to strip away rights
that you know you should be you should
be given or you're or that you're born
with right
um
and that's Republican party it is
completely full of projection you it you
cannot and that talking point there
doesn't ever get old because every
single day there's a new story there's a
new accusation whatever it might be is
proving that that party is guilty of the
very thing that they're they're accusing
others of being
absolutely absolutely they're the
Republican party today is useless it's
useless it's rotten to the core you know
Rhonda you were talking about Ron
DeSantis earlier Tony I just did a a an
entire show last night on Ron DeSantis
he
you know ship those Folks up to Martha's
Vineyard spent 12 million dollars
everybody says how many how much water
would 12 million dollars have bought but
then again
he made the hypocrisy meter explode
because his people are now up in New
York
recruiting those same Venezuelan
migrants
to come work in Florida to clean up This
Disaster Area they're offering them
fifteen dollars an hour to work in the
most contaminated
[ __ ] up environment you've ever seen
there's dead people dead dogs feces
chemicals this is a horrendous job it's
Hazard pay is what they should be
getting and then they're offering them
15 a day per diem for food
yeah so you're not going to see any
buses going from Abbott or DeSantis for
a while because they're going to use
them in Florida
and it the [ __ ] hypocrisy of it man
these people are [ __ ] stains on Humanity
they just
make me sick and then of course you know
you've already talked about the story
I'm sure about uh they've privatized
their disaster release fund Relief Fund
and it's a [ __ ] 501c3 charity run by
desantis's wife they're gonna steal
money is what they're gonna do
yeah she's like she's a she's a goddamn
team local TV anchor
he's a local TV anchor you know Michelle
Obama was an executive in a Health Care
system
you know this woman knew how to manage
money assets resources and people
Cassidy DeSantis is a [ __ ]
local television station news anchor
what the [ __ ] does she know about
disaster relief what needs to be done
well she knows how to steal money she's
going to get advice from old DeSantis I
mean that's the fact of the matter here
is that and I think is what you're
trying to drive at with this whole
conversation is that the Republican
party again like you said is rotten to
the core but it is like a [ __ ] sandwich
eating a [ __ ] sandwich and it is not
hard like I said as when the hurricane
was on its way to Florida I said Ron
DeSantis is totally gonna [ __ ] this up
and I don't need to know anything more
than it's Ron DeSantis who is the
governor that's all I need to know I
don't need to know anything past that
point just like in Georgia we watch this
drama play out on Twitter last night and
this morning of Herschel Walker and his
son well you didn't need to know
anything more anything more that it was
Herschel Walker and Donald Trump
endorsed him to know that this was gonna
go south just like the Dr Oz and you
know Dr Oz is probably be happy this
morning because him [ __ ] torturing
animals is now out of the news and
Christian Walker and his dad fighting is
in the news
I don't you know what I'm not paying a
[ __ ] bit of attention to that
warnock's gonna kick the [ __ ] out of him
I don't give a [ __ ] about
I didn't give a [ __ ] about Herschel
Walker I do care about all of these
Floridians you're talking about these
the United States home of boats okay
I've got a bay boat guys I do I've got a
nice bait boat I can run in a foot of
water one foot 12 inches of water and I
can drive my boat through it I mean it
they are all over Florida I love the
saltwater fish they are all over Florida
Sanibel Island all the burial islands
out there
they've got people out there desperate
for water and food today why we're
having this conversation right in the
home of [ __ ] boats
you're telling me nobody has put
together
a warehouse a distribution system I
don't know told people hey bring your
[ __ ] boats and bring your ass here
like we did in Houston you remember in
Houston when we had Harvey boats running
up and down the street picking people up
you know they were reporting to local
officials that were telling them
coordinating with them telling them
check this road okay we've checked that
road check it off you know I mean yeah
they were going house to house to house
to try to get people out Republicans
cannot [ __ ] do this because they're
not there to govern I [ __ ] you not
Rhonda Santos is at a [ __ ] Waffle
House
a [ __ ] Waffle House doing a photo op
and we still have people stranded we
still have I if I was a governor
I could not sleep until I knew
everything was running like a well-oiled
machine and people were being rescued
and I mean I might you couldn't keep my
ass out of a boat
that's because though that's because you
actually have the low bar of decency
that's the problem here is we can't even
we can't even get the Republican party
and its leaders to reach the low bar of
just plain human decency and that's why
I knew he was gonna fail there was no
way Ron DeSantis was going to be able to
to make to make it happen to where all
Floridians and this and this was done in
the most proper way he failed the moment
the storm hit Fort Myers because he
didn't warn those people the governor
has the ability to send out a warning
and he did not he did not send out a
warning for those people to evacuate
and if you've seen the video you know
that it should have been given
hours in advance to get as many people
out of those places as possible and like
you said he shows up in Saint Augustine
with out in a pair of white boots
flipping waffles where there's a few
down branches and you know the thing is
people in Florida understand that [ __ ]
because what Rhonda santis is doing and
here's what he's doing Texas Paul
he's playing a national game here he's
not playing the game for Florida he's
not he's playing the game to run for
president in 2024 and he knows that he
can't piss off his his Tail Waggers all
around the country
he can't piss that he can piss
Floridians off you know what's the big
deal he can't piss off the Tail Waggers
all around the country the the
moguladites the America First Nazi party
and he's playing that right that's
what's the problem with the entire
Republican party is the culture they
that's why you can have every Republican
in Florida vote against or Marco Rubio
will not even show up for the vote
because Democrats
you know guys do you know why they did
that you know why they voted against
that money
I didn't want to give Democrats a win as
if it was a win for Democrats not a win
for Floridians what do you think there
is you know you know political strategy
there's always political strategy you
win some you lose some the Democrats got
them there was gonna they wanted to shut
down they wanted to make a big thing
they had a big media push ready for
defunding the Biden Administration the
criminal Biden Administration they're
criminals look you know remember Mark
Howe the guy they're Prosecuting they're
saying oh this poor he loves babies and
they're just Prosecuting him because
he's anti-abortion and he really beat up
a 72 year old guy twice you know what I
mean it's like [ __ ] like that just they
they this big push that the bidens were
criminals they wanted to defund the
government
the debt ceiling vote was coming up so
the Democrats have foxed and they said
fine we had a hurricane we need to fund
FEMA all the FEMA funding is in the debt
ceiling Bill vote mm-hmm
instead of taking the L and saying okay
that didn't work
they did it anyways
they've literally tried to shut down the
government that's what those no votes
were for they wanted to shut down the
government in the middle I mean three
days in two days into this [ __ ]
relief the worst disaster or you know
Florida state is called Rhonda Santos
called it a 500 year storm by the way
yeah he called out a 500 year storm
and every Republican still played this
[ __ ] game
the game like you said was worth more to
them
than helping the people that they're
supposed to be helping right I mean
you're looking for constituents you know
we we've shown the clips before is like
you show you show Ron DeSantis on Tucker
Carlson and he plays the game of like I
had to request I had to request the
money from Joe Biden as opposed to Joe
Biden already being like hey money
resources whatever you need we've got
you because you are Americans you are
part of the United States there's no
reason why I would cut you off from any
sort of funding or help when there's
people's lives and and well-being at
risk and then you've also got that uh
Stu Studio guy or whatever the [ __ ] his
name is he's he's on there being like I
wrote a letter to Joe Biden and he had
to sign that letter for us to get and
it's like but just a few days prior Joe
Biden had already said hey look this is
what we're doing we're giving the money
like I'm already I'm already calling
this a disaster this is something that's
already going to get our attention I'm
at FEMA I'm having conversations I'm
dealing with Logistics I'm actually
running this country like a president
and not picking and choosing who gets
help and who doesn't get help and the
Republican Party
is going to vote against their
constituents right they're going to take
the money as they want it because
they're going to grift you know Ron
desantis's wife that party will take
away from others that they're supposed
to be representing and then they'll
blame it on some and again it's the
projection they'll blame it on others
and be like whoa look dude I I I told
them I wrote them a very strongly worded
email and a tweet and the truth social
post or whatever the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that they write and said I I told Joe
Biden I told Joe Biden that he had to do
what I said and he had to help my people
meanwhile Joe Biden is doing it
and they're they're voting against it
but their narrative has to be we vote
well we voted against it because there
was pork in there there was something
else in there God forbid we help some
other region that was affected by
Hurricane Ian or what have you but
because it wasn't directly all the money
to this person or to this group in
Florida then we have to say oh no no no
no no no we had to vote against it it
was for your well-being you wouldn't you
know just just calm yourself down I know
what's best for you because I'm the
governor or I'm the representative or
I'm the senator I mean all of these
[ __ ] idiots are incompetent and they
should not be running a state let alone
a state that every year goes through
this same [ __ ] thing the same type of
natural disaster and doesn't prepare
them you have 365 days sometimes less
than that but you know due to Science
and Technology we can track this we know
the pattern in which it goes we can say
hey we predict this is the pattern it's
going to go through so we we want to
make sure that we have people on the
ready to repair lines we've got people
on the ready to disperse resources but
instead they sit with their hands like
sit on their hands and say
okay well
this storm came out of nowhere guys we
couldn't have predicted it it's it's
it's frustrating it's frustrating it's
what it is well but it's the same thing
that you were talking about earlier
Texas Paul at this at the Border in
Texas where it's this it's the same
[ __ ] the same [ __ ] where they
use they use what is reality and they
use it to spend it in their little
stupid way and they and they don't
actually do the thing that is like
policy and governing treating people
like human beings and and just doing the
thing that you need to do which is uh
govern
they don't do that and they're not and
again that's why it's so easy to predict
how much they're going to fail because
they suck at this they totally suck at
this and really honestly it's
intentional they're they're they're
they're sucking of government is
completely intentional it's to tear down
your democracy tear down your ability to
want to even participate and once you
stop participating they have full
control to do whatever the hell they
want steal whatever the hell they want
treat people however the hell they want
and that is why we have to lean into
democracy that's why we have to pay
attention that's why I love having you
here on Tuesdays because I think I think
the situation in Florida with this storm
and the situation at the border can be
boiled down to you know what you're not
going to stop people from coming across
the border to seek Asylum they want to
come here it's a legal process and
you're not going to stop people from
illegally crossing to come here for work
because the [ __ ] [ __ ] process to come
here legally for work is so stupid it's
ridiculous because no [ __ ] Republican
will sit in a room and make sure that
that process is done in a simple form so
people can come here and contribute to
our economy legally when it's just much
easier to just cross illegally and work
it's the same situation you know A
hurricane's going to hit Florida you
know what it you know that the damage
could be great and you sit on your
[ __ ] hands and do nothing even after
it's done and over with it's the same
[ __ ] Republican way the same thing
whether you're in Florida right now with
the disaster are are you talking about
the southern Border in Texas same [ __ ]
you know little man what you were
talking about it being intentional this
is what's going to happen in Florida
this is intentional they are funneling
all of their their efforts through you
know you've got the Florida defense fund
well there's there's another half to
that it's volunteer Florida is the other
half of it that's where they do the
actual cleanup and [ __ ] like that is
through volunteer Florida which is tied
to the Florida defense fund this [ __ ]
charity
they're setting it up to intentionally
[ __ ] fail in Florida and then they
were going to going to turn around and
try to blame Biden because they know for
a fact FEMA will not work with the
Florida defense fund they don't work
that way FEMA does not work through
layers of an onion
FEMA goes to the Red Cross
and says what do you need FEMA goes to
the Salvation Army and says what do you
need FEMA does not go to the Florida
defense fund and say Here's my checkbook
go pay these people because they don't
need to pay salaries in between here and
there they have people on the ground
there
to help Catholic Charities distribute
clothes that's what FEMA does and how
FEMA Works they've got a volunteer army
it's called crew it's it's a the it's a
reserve uh it's a job you can get with
with FEMA it you don't work until
there's a disaster and then they call
you up and you go and they pay you very
well to go do clean up or managers to go
out and meet with ngos and and stuff
like that they'll work with local
you know cities and state workers
absolutely
if State Workers are like man we don't
have enough equipment feed them is like
equipment
we'll rent it we got it without you no
problem whatever you need we're there
but they will not [ __ ] cut checks to
organizations like
uh the floor the Florida disaster fund
they will not put that layer in between
what they're doing and DeSantis knows
this that's why he's intentionally one
telling everybody this is where you
donate
this is where you donate don't send
money or food or I mean don't send food
or or water or anything like that send
money directly to this fund but he knows
FEMA's already there but FEMA is not
working with these people they're not
they're not going to work with these
people they they that's not how they
operate that's why when you saw in
Puerto Rico
FEMA had a [ __ ] ton of water sitting on
the docks
they had made arrangements with ngos to
distribute it
and the [ __ ] uh
sorry ass I can't remember his name uh
the president of Puerto Rico that
corrupt [ __ ] wanted to put his
company in there to distribute that
water
and FEMA's like it's delivered we made
arrangements that's what we do
you want to [ __ ] your people that's on
you and that's the same thing that's
going to happen
unless it gets to be Katrina bat if it
gets to be Katrina level bad the federal
government will federal law is this
response which to me looking at this
whole cluster [ __ ] DeSantis has set up
needs to happen immediately we we need
to learn from Katrina
and say you cannot do this right you
cannot [ __ ] do this you just made a
TV anchor in charge of your disaster
relief you are [ __ ] incompetent and
they need to federalize the National
Guard down there and FEMA needs to take
over now instead of waiting until people
are dying from [ __ ] dysentery out on
Sanibel Island
you know I mean it's just
you see it Tony you see it Gabe I see it
anybody that's watching what's going on
down in Florida Jesus Christ they're
pulling dead kids out of the Lee County
Juvenile Facility because the [ __ ]
Republican Sheriff down there would not
Evacuate the juvenile facility [ __ ]
crazy
they're pulling dead kids out of this
jail right now
but DeSantis is going to lie about it
DeSantis is going to lie he lied about
covet he lied about he was he is not
going to be a reliable source of
information and he's not going to be a
reliable partner to work with he's not
well he's either because he's a [ __ ]
Republican he's either gonna lie or he's
not going to acknowledge it I mean we've
already seen the early developments of
his strategy which is I'm going to go to
the opposite side of the state that had
little damage and show how much good is
happening right now because of our
strategy and our plan but really he's
just ignoring the west side of the state
that was completely ravaged by this
hurricane and so by not acknowledging it
right by focusing all the effort am I
flipping pancakes at a Waffle House or
you know heading water out and in in
Saint Augustine or areas that aren't
actually uh
devastated right he's wearing his
[ __ ] white water boot like whatever I
don't know what the [ __ ] he's wearing
but it's all performative it's all
performative nothing he's doing is
actually helping the people of Florida
and the people he's given his attention
to in drawing a distraction from he's
not actually helping right he's going
around like oh look some branches went
down like yeah to the same extent that
when it's windy here in La palm trees
fall apart right
but in Florida he's completely ignoring
the part of the state that was actually
hurt that was actually having people
that suffered lost their homes their
livelihood their family members he's
ignoring those people and by not
acknowledging it he's very much taken
the Trump approach which is like I'm not
responsible
you know if I don't like out of sight
out of mind and that is what Republicans
do if I don't see it and we don't talk
about it it was never really there right
and that is what a strategy is whether
to lie or just flat out ignore
and just like trying to shut down the
government in the middle of a natural
disaster they're going to say your fault
right it's your fault right you're it's
your fault
Brandon did this Brandon did this I
didn't do it I tried like Gabe said I
sent a memo I sent a memo you know well
and that's and that's and that's the
story of the Republican party here is
that they don't want to govern because
they know governing's hard and it's hard
to re when you actually govern for the
people it's really hard to screw the
people it's really hard if you if you
really focus on governing for the people
who elected you and for your
constituents it's really hard to [ __ ]
them in the end it's really hard to so
what you do is you just point the finger
with projection at the other side while
you're taking the money taking the power
taking all the fruit for yourself that
way your constituents get [ __ ] and you
blame it on the other side because
they're the ones they're the ones I mean
if this hurricane had not hit Florida my
guess is every single Republican
Congressman the the governor of Florida
the Senators Republican senators from
Florida would say abolish FEMA abolish
fee FEMA they would be wanting to
abolish FEMA but now they love FEMA they
love FEMA today because they're going to
steal they're going to steal from it not
only are they going to steal not only
going to steal the effort and the
recovery that FEMA actually is
organizing but they're going to steal
they're going to try to steal the
[ __ ] money it is going to happen
folks that's what they do that is what
they do
and Tony I tell you you got me right
here in the fields and that one in in
that opening because you're absolutely
right you're absolutely right it can't
just be me and you and Gabe screaming
hey this is going on this and the other
people have to pull their heads out of
the Kardashians asses for a minute stop
watching all the pop pop culture
[ __ ] and focus on what's [ __ ]
going on because I'm telling you folks
this is your last chance
if you [ __ ] this up and you give
Republicans power I if you let the
Republicans even take the house
we are [ __ ]
we as a country are [ __ ] like you've
never seen
these people are insane
they are insane [ __ ]
don't give a [ __ ] we'll watch you die
kind of people
they they
I can't stress it hard enough
it can't just be us you know it cannot
just be us I got I I got four voters
yesterday guys I got four voters one of
them I took my wife to Red Lobster and
we went to lunch at Red Lobster and my
waitress was there and I'm like are you
registered to vote she's like yes my mom
made me promise to go register for to
vote and I did and I said okay well look
look let me tell you something let me
tell you why
not just you have to vote you have to
get one of your friends to vote because
you see that guy at that table right
there and I pointed over there and of
course I'm sitting at a dinner table
I've got my hat off it's sitting in a
chair you know you've got this guy who
walked in with a American Flag t-shirt
that turned into AR-15s draping down you
know what I mean really this is the guy
it sounds like you will not stop my
writing he had a beard like my old beard
before I shaved it off you know and I
told her and she happened to be
African-American she was a wonderful
person Alexis if you see this you were
wonderful human being
I said that racist [ __ ] right
there
is going to vote
your vote is going to cancel out his
vote that's right but for us to win you
have to bring one more person with you
that's right right because that's how we
get ahead that's right if you vote just
you all you're doing is canceling that
racist [ __ ] vote out
you have to bring somebody with you and
she was like wow I I never thought about
it that way and I'm like but that's the
truth it can't just be me voting it
can't be just the people in the chat
people in our bubble we have to get busy
get out there get people you go through
a drive-through recruit somebody
mm-hmm you go to dinner recruit somebody
you go to Walmart recruit somebody
everywhere you go you got to be talking
about this for the next month man
October 11th is deadline here in Texas
people you have to be registered by
October 11th after October 11th I can
get no more voters if they're not
already registered got a few more days
folks get out there and check your
registration check other people's
registration as well make sure they are
registered to vote get your buddy system
going that's right that's right Texas
Paul I always enjoy having you here on
Tuesdays I know the audience does too
and I I hate to go because
um I I love talking about all this stuff
and but we really got to get to the [ __ ]
list Roundup I got I got some Herschel
wall I know you don't want to talk about
Erza Walker but I got I gotta run down
through this and why this is so
important why this is so important to
the election because I think that's
that's what people need to understand
and I said it in the beginning that this
Herschel Walker story yeah it's about
him and his son but really the person
that's terrified the most morning that's
[ __ ] their diapers in Georgia is
Kemp is Governor Kemp this is bad for
him this is really bad for him and his
campaign and I'll explain that but Texas
Paul tell us where we can find you jelly
as to where the audience can find you I
know you have some stuff going over on
YouTube now tell them what they can do
over there on YouTube for you this
Wednesday 99 p.m Central we have TNT me
and Tennessee Brando get together and
break down what's going on and on
Sundays at uh nine a our pardon me I
moved it to 10 because a lot of the West
coasters were like please don't make me
get up this early please
so I said okay 10 o'clock uh in the
morning central time we're doing uh
coffee with Texas Paul we just have a
nice conversation about what's going on
when of course take questions from the
chat or at the end of every show so
that's great enjoy it folks come see me
yeah go go follow go follow And
subscribe it's free it's subscribe on
YouTube to Texas balls Channel and he's
got a free show over there for you two
of them every single week it's easy to
find and I got a link tree up it's link
uh there's a link tr.e slash Texas Paul
that's great that's great
um the Texas Paul thanks for joining us
everyone stick around we'll be right
back with the [ __ ] list Roundup right
after this break my friend you have a
good one we'll see you next Tuesday best
podcast jump bad cop best podcast there
is guys the best podcast
at old time and he fumbles there at the
end thanks a lot Texas boy I appreciate
it we'll talk to you soon my friend
everyone go follow Texas Paul's Channel
on YouTube we'll talk everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
this break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
abortion abortion abortion what an issue
I would think I would think that if
there was a United States Senator
running
in a forced birther away and he'd want
to force women at Birth that he probably
should not be paying
for said abortions it would probably be
a thing that he wouldn't want to do I
don't know I'm just guessing maybe Gabe
maybe not I mean I mean I don't know I
would say that it it definitely Falls in
line with another person from Georgia
who says uh I hey I want my own privacy
to my own life as a woman right and
Marjorie Taylor green says that but then
also wants to be the one that says you
don't have rights of privacy as a woman
so when you see another Republican
another Maga uh you know America first
uh Christian nationalist candidate who
says Ah the rules don't apply to me but
they do to you right it's it is it is
something again that shows the hypocrisy
of you're gonna say because Herschel
Walker's position on abortion is there
is no exception and it's murder it's
murder exactly murdered her and to
Herschel Walker the value of a life and
I said it yesterday uh obviously was
dropped I said the valuable life to
Herschel Walker is seven hundred dollars
I mean plus or minus the whatever the
cost of a a Hallmark get well card is
right but that's what they that's that
is their party right of course
Republican candidates or people in in in
as lawmakers have gotten an abortion to
say they haven't would be ridiculous you
know there's a fair amount of people in
life that we all probably know or don't
know because they haven't told us and
they want to keep it to themselves that
probably have had an abortion sure it's
a very intimate thing that is that part
of their life
whether they choose to reveal that and
say that or not
that's up to them that is their right it
is their body and their choice
but the thing that is so frustrating is
how much the Republican party wants to
project their own issues onto others you
can't do this you can't say that you
can't have this when in reality they're
the ones who are like I can have those
things and I can choose what I do with
them when I want
well you know because I think I think
fake Gabe was calling us baby killers in
the um in the chat for a while it's not
actually a baby yeah he was gone I think
he was gone this baby which um you
didn't kill them what you want to talk
about Herschel Walker wow what's funny
what's funny about this is
the reason why they get stuck in these
positions right why fake Gabe is always
running in circles and why Hershel
Walker is now in a position where he has
to say oh it's all lies he can't
actually explain what happened right the
reason why is because they don't really
tether themselves to any kind of reality
and the reality is is that there's
abortion Services out there
there's abortion services and they are
abortion Services they're not killing a
human life that's not what it's doing
that's you're not killing a baby and a
lot of times abortion services are
making sure that the woman survives a
dead baby yep like there's a dead baby
inside of her and the problem is is that
these people just do not tether
themselves to facts and they go out in
front of microphones and they tell or
they they say [ __ ] in front of a
microphone that people are telling them
because here's the real problem with
Herschel Walker other than he's just
he's not he's not a smart dude he's just
not smart and I don't know if it's a CTE
or he's just a dummy but the guy's got
some um mental health issues as it were
and so does his son Christian they both
obviously have mental health issues
um that's one of the problems that we
have in this country is why we're being
distracted by people calling
women who have to have medical abortion
Services baby killers were being
distracted by that these people aren't
getting the mental health that they need
and I'm talking about Herschel and
Christian Walker but here's the thing
Herschel Walker the reason why every
time you hear him speak it sounds like
what in the what the [ __ ] is he talking
about the reason why is because someone
are a group of people his campaign has
told him what he needs to say and then
he tries to go out and say and repeat
that thing
right yeah he doesn't actually believe
any of this stuff no he doesn't believe
it he's not a Christian that's all
[ __ ] Christian Walker has even said
it's all [ __ ] lies yeah now it's hard
to believe anything that Christian
Walker actually says right and here's
the and everyone some people been
simping for him like I'll leave the guy
alone he's [ __ ] the dude is simping
for Rhonda Santos in the same breath a
lying sack of [ __ ] so if you're sick of
the lies then be sick of the lies and
again I I messaged Christian
um to tell him to come on the show and
hopefully he'll get back to me I hope he
will because I'll bring him on the show
and I told him it wasn't going to be
easy like it's going to be tough
questions right and it's going to be
straightforward
um but
but the simple fact that
um this Herschel Walker thing has
ballooned into what it is is not
surprising
um obviously in the span of let's see
the news dropped yesterday and what time
six or something like that yeah yeah it
was late yesterday it was late yesterday
yeah but I mean we're talking you know
within 18 hours or so this has blown up
from The Daily Beast saying hey so
remember when we said that he had these
three kids that he wasn't uh you know
publicly uh taking uh taking in you know
or like accepting you know he was
denying them well guess what we also
found out that he had an abortion
surprise surprise and he paid for it and
he gave her a get well card and then and
this was a girlfriend this is while he
was married and this is just someone he
was his his side piece as as some would
say right that that he was and that's
how he viewed it did you see the [ __ ]
image of the card
oh yeah yeah yeah I mean I mean
can you imagine okay so you're you're
you're
paying for an abortion for someone and
and that you've had an affair with
right and you go into the gas station
right and you're gonna send this person
a 700 check because you feel like you
need to pay them 700 bucks pay for the
medical procedure that they're gonna
have
um to make sure that she's not pregnant
to save face so you don't have another
child that you have to disown
and there's again this is not this can't
be the only abortion that Herschel
Walker has paid for it can't be oh no no
no no no no but here's the thing is
you're right out of check for 700 bucks
and you're like okay I can just put this
in an envelope but he thought at least
he had the fourth out in a decency to be
like I'll get a card can you imagine
though picking out this particular card
for this instance right like I just I
don't understand why this card is the
confusing part I understand why Herschel
Walker paid for the abortion I
understand why the woman wanted to get
the abortion I understand why he wanted
to hide the fact because he's got to
pretend he's someone he's not I get all
I understand all that like I get all
that whole thing he he was married he he
had an affair she ended up pregnant I
mean I get the whole thing like that
story makes all the sense in the world
the thing that doesn't make sense to me
is the card he picked out that really
does not make sense to me now the other
thing I want to know
and and this goes to Democrats actually
playing elections really well yeah and
all the Republicans and all you magas
all you fake games in the chat you can
go [ __ ] yourselves because this is
beautiful this is [ __ ] beautiful this
is exactly exactly what Republicans
always do because I'm telling you I'm
telling you Democrats have the [ __ ]
Goods on your candidates and the reason
why they have the goods on your
candidates because they're they're
Trump's candidates yeah you dumb
[ __ ] I don't know how many
times I have to tell you this you are
not going to win in national elections
in in the future because we are [ __ ]
pissed off we are pissed off we're tired
of your nonsense and frankly the
majority of the country is tired of the
[ __ ] nonsense there were so many
people cheering yesterday that the truth
came to light with Herschel Walker the
truth that they already knew and then
they were cheering when Christian Walker
was burning his campaign to the [ __ ]
ground I mean he is burning Herschel
Walker's campaign to the absolute ground
because not only is Christian Walker
saying I can't stand it anymore I can't
take the drama I can't do this I can't
do that he's saying all the [ __ ] that
ursha Walker's saying to you people out
there in Georgia is all lies all lies
it's all [ __ ] none of it's true he
is absolutely burning down his campaign
and the person who is who is terrified
of this the most
is Kemp Governor Kemp because it is
going to affect the turnout it's going
to affect the turnout this is what
Republicans have always done so well
Gabe how they affect the turnout they
get they get people so so frustrated
with a Democrat candidate or a Democrat
candidate somewhere else that they're
asked to stay at home and don't
understand that the rest of those races
are [ __ ] important
and that's what we've done to turn it
around in the narrative and the [ __ ]
because Herschel Walker is a [ __ ] box
it's not our fault I I don't know what
tell you you picked him
what am I supposed to do I mean like
look you guys I'm sorry that you didn't
vet this person right I'm sorry that you
propped up someone who is a a former
athlete with probably CTE and has a
difficult time kind of pushing his own
opinion in his own perspective and his
own policies you've heard him talk about
the dirty air from China you've heard
him talk about uh how he he feels about
abortion you've heard him talk about uh
you know claiming to be in law
enforcement I'm literally working on a
what was that right now to break down
Herschel Walker and The I have a section
where I literally cannot go through all
of the lies and it's just a scrolling
list School law enforcement owning a
business this that like all of these
things that he has been either yeah a
hypocrite about has just boldface lied
about for years but look a lot of the
stuff and the same goes for what what
happened to Trump if you
they probably could have kept living
their lives making money no one would
have actually you know second guessed
them or said anything but as soon as you
enter that Spotlight of running for
office that [ __ ] is Gonna Come Out
people are gonna be snooping around
they're gonna be digging through your
[ __ ] they're gonna be looking up every
possible to lifting up every stone
looking for any dirt that they have on
you
so I'm sorry that your group was unable
to properly vet a character who clearly
has a lot of lies and a lot of issues
going on
at home in business whatever his
personal life is all of those things now
look I don't like Christian Walker I'll
be straight up about it I don't like the
things that he says I don't like the
fact that he's an [ __ ] I don't like
that he's an [ __ ] I don't like the
the way he treats people I don't like
the way that he's transphobic I don't
like the way that he's has his own
self-hatred and whether that is born out
of the household that he was in you know
through the Republican party and through
his father or whatever or feeling like
he has to belong or feel like he has to
be accepted you know like hurt people
hurt people and that is what this is
right I I I am glad that he spoke up you
know there's a lot of me that that uh I
I do feel for someone in a broken home
like that right uh you know all the
things that he said you know with the
way the treatment that his mother
received that he received like we
already know Herschel Walker is an
abusive person right played Russian
roulette with himself had had held gun
to Christians mom's Temple right this
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] insane
so when you see this come out I'm like
good good because you guys didn't do
your homework you didn't do your [ __ ]
research yeah when you should have and
you guys propped up a candidate that
pretty much is just a puppet and you
tell them to say things like Tony said
and he says them right he won't he won't
deviate he might kind of in a confused
way jumble some words around you might
be like what the [ __ ] were you talking
about it's word salad just words you
know last night he goes on Sean Hannity
and he says oh did you ever pay the 700
he goes well I paid a lot of people some
money I don't right right I know I I
know a lot you know what you know what's
funny is I I tweeted out the to one of
the clips I was like does it feel like
to you that that Trump coached him on
this a little bit there was some Trump
coaching somewhere now rather it was
like directly or or indirectly like they
went back and looked at the the uh the
Access Hollywood response the grab them
by the [ __ ] thing and and they were
like well let's just copy this this will
work yeah um but the problem is
Churchill Walker so he just he doesn't
really he doesn't get it he doesn't he
doesn't I've seen and and I I want to
comment because this isn't the only time
I've seen this comment so fake Gabe says
why would he hide the abortion I've seen
these comments not only that but I've
seen comments that literally are
attacking uh Christian Walker for
speaking out about this abuse and the uh
the the life he had oh the right Wing's
pissed off at Christian this morning
because they're like what are you doing
shut up stop ruining our campaign like
they're still backing Herschel like yeah
we want this guy everyone on the left
was like a baby killer right and
everyone on the left is like look
Christian you're just a pawn you're just
this thing that they're putting up on a
mantle to say oh look we have someone
who is Black who is gay who doesn't
associate with these you know the
Socialist you know agenda of the left or
whatever he supports the right he's a
republican we can't be racist we can't
be bigoted transphobic homophobic
whatever we have someone on our side
we've got a a Tim Scott we've got a
Herschel Walker Kanye West Candace Owens
Candace Owens we have all these people
you know I I said last night I was on I
was on a space a Twitter spaces last
night I said Christian Walker is one
white lives matter shirt away from
becoming Candace Owens and Kanye West
like that is the extent I mean he hasn't
worn the clothing yet but he said that
crazy [ __ ] which is promoting white
supremacy going against his own people
against any person of color I mean we
know that Christian Walker got a voice
during the protest in the summer of 2020
and that is where the Republican Party
really said oh look this kid doesn't
look like us white people us straight
white people so we need to prop him up
and that is really where Christian got
his voice and really where he got his
kind of quote-unquote brand that he
developed which was this uh
pro-conservative
anti-blue-haired Liberal Liberal ghetto
fascist or you know uh consumer a
communist state of California and that
by the way I just want to point out he
moved to Florida
in just last week he had a video crying
about how he missed California so
why is that why is that he could he
couldn't possibly miss a Marxist
socialist place like California no when
he said you know he's like maybe maybe
it's a transition thing or what have you
but he was very upset and very emotional
about the fact that he had moved he's
like I just kind of up and went and I
didn't really think about it and I was
like I mean sucks to suck in the sense
that you left a state that was actually
providing you services that were helpful
to you as opposed to Florida and then
now you living in Florida where there's
natural disasters and the governor that
you [ __ ] support loves he loves it he
loves
he continues despite all this he
continues to prop him up and say oh this
guy's great so I I'm gonna get to the
[ __ ] list around up here so we can show
fake Gabe the um the videos he keep he
keeps questioning this story about the
abortion and Christian Wong I don't know
why he said better hope this story is
true Super PAC I don't know what Super
PAC is what super fast touch oh we're
trying to say hey hey fake Gabe hey fake
Gabe we here at the Johnny Michaels
podcast are not a Super Peg we are not
part of the minus touch Super PAC we
don't have anything to do with their
Super PAC that's not anything we do we
produce our podcast here and minus touch
partners with us to distribute it you
[ __ ] loser yeah and you're all over
it and you're all over you're all over
their page so welcome welcome to the
super Pacs page where you can't stop
talking about us and it's wonderful I
love having here because you you give us
so much content to to put up on the tee
and hit out I'm not really sure also
what the story is he's hoping is true I
don't know I know the whole the whole
idea that we're part of a super I do not
have I do not receive any salary any
money from any Super PAC whatsoever uh I
don't receive money from George Soros as
much as I would love to right as much as
you think that's an own to own the libs
I don't receive money from them I
literally make money through content
creation and also Contracting work
through right through art art baby art
so so fake I'm not sure which story
you're referring to here that you better
we better hope it's true but let's do
this Gabe let's go to the [ __ ] let's
round up the show fake game here the
video of it's not a deep fake it's his
video on his channel two videos it's
real it's real so let's do this let's
surf to Tweety tweets and the trendy
Trends so we can watch this [ __ ]
Walker household meltdown let's start
the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
about the Tweety tweets and journey
Trends and boy do we have a lot of stuff
to get to today a lot of Floridians that
I want to get to today but first off we
gotta start with this [ __ ] Herschel
Walker Christian Walker thing now I
could show all the tweets
but we would be here for an extra five
hours if we had to go through it just
wait I'm we'll see how far I get it I
don't know I I'm literally Dave's kind
of what was that that's what he's trying
this as it happens like I've got most of
it written because it's ongoing I mean
it's I wasn't expecting the videos to
come out this morning but that that's an
added little element to it right this
whole thing like this what's crazy is
out you were texting me as this was
happening and I said wait you gotta and
this was before Christian started
tweeting right I said you gotta wait for
the Herschel Walker explanation video
because that word salad is gonna be
delicious right and it was it was on
brand it was perfect it was exactly what
you would expect then more on the space
game and everyone's like oh his account
was hacked and he's like nope he's
sharing it on Instagram as well you're
right he's pushing it everywhere and
then he came out with a video now this
is the second video that he put out this
morning I actually think this video is
more telling of Christian Walker and his
dad and why this this is an a problem in
the first place right like this explains
the entire issue of what the Republican
party has like this is the core betted
issue and frankly I think this is the
off ramp that Trump president can take
here
um I don't like Christian Walker he is
an [ __ ] he will continue to be an
[ __ ] it would take a lot for him for
me to go you know what okay I think
you've changed it would take a lot for
me to believe that but also in the first
video because we're playing the second
one in the first video he literally says
he's like if you know that's fine you
don't like me you don't like my politics
you don't like what I say
he's not excusing
the traumatic
kind of upbringing and likely he had
because his father he's not blaming the
politics and the things that he believes
in on that
he's taught like the only thing that
he's talking about right now is just the
relationship and his dad as a candidate
he's not blaming his beliefs and his his
ideologies on his father those are his
own
and he even says that you can hate me
for this you can hate me for that
but don't come at me for this Dad [ __ ]
but this one here he specifically goes
on a rant here about lies let's listen
and just two more things I have to
address and then I'm done with this
buffoonery Nut Job land this is
atrocious
people on the right are pulling up that
I did a campaign event with my dad last
year they're saying well you supported
them all last year
last year no no you all have been
why aren't you on the Canadian Trail
with your dad why aren't you helping him
out this looks weird you should go help
him and I've said to you calmly I'm not
getting involved
you don't know my family life I did one
event last year when we were told he was
going to get ahead of his past and hold
himself accountable none of that
happened okay so he's talking about the
event that happened at Mar-A-Lago yeah I
think that's what he said yeah December
of 2021 was the event that Christian
Walker gave a speech on behalf of his
dad and his quote unquote Uncle Don
which is Donald Trump
and said how much you know the radical
left and Democrats want to ruin America
and this and that and family values and
these things and blah blah blah all this
[ __ ] that is just same old [ __ ] yakity
schmackity from Christian Walker same
[ __ ]
and now now in that because what he who
he's talking about here is uh Jack
prostate and I did I get his last name
right that's a pronouncer right jack
prostate
prostate
prostasis prostasis okay Jack pro stasis
so he's talking about the pizza the
pizza gate guy as Jack is known for his
conspiracy theories for Pizza King
because Jack I mean dude he was losing
his [ __ ] mind on Twitter he was like
oh you're a traitor because you're
telling the truth you're abandoning all
the lies like that's like what are you
talking about because Christian Walker
clearly is laying out here hey I lied to
he's saying out loud I lied to you he's
telling his social media following that
he lied to them and he's tired of it
listen everything's been a lie so for me
to tell you I'm not getting involved and
then you also be flooding my DMs and
calling me saying I didn't know all this
about your Dad we're gonna lose the
centuries and then when I simply say I'm
done with the lies you go well Christian
looks suspicious excuse me I haven't
told one story about what I experienced
with him I'm just simply saying don't
lie and then for for certain political
pundits to be pulling up old pictures I
posted of my dad thinking they can
police and and determine what my
relationship with my dad was if you want
to pull stuff up I'll post stuff up now
this is I text you last night or this
morning it was this morning I texted you
and I said hey I think he's talking
about you in this video because you were
one of the first ones to go to Instagram
and start spreading because I remember I
mean like I here's the thing
For Better or Worse
uh I I discovered Christian during the
pandemic and I make videos uh that are
used to debunk the talking points that
he has the election covet and you
pretend to be his roommate when I make
fun of you because every once in a while
I'll text if Christian comes up and news
I'm like hey your roommate's out of
control right can you get him back on
track you know and so so I make these
videos you know out of comedic relief
but also to point out these talking
points that the Republican party has
either been regurgitating on Fox news or
oan or whatever and I use it as that you
know like obviously he becomes the butt
of the joke because he's the one saying
these things but I use it as a way to
directly kind of call out these lies
that he says or just the ridiculous
things that he that he said about random
things
um and so I discovered Christian that
way and so now I'm kind of like on this
like Christian Walker tracker which is
any of the [ __ ] that comes out it's
blocky remote social media though right
so you've had to open up sock puppets
just just to see his stuff like so I'll
I'll send Gabe something from
Christian's account I'm like hey turn on
your socks he said I needed something
this morning and I wasn't able to view
it because Christian Walker had blocked
my account uh Herschel Walker also
blocked my account oh wow that's like a
trophy right no one ever blocks me what
the hell I mean damn bongino has blocked
me but you know that's not surprising he
blogs like everyone and Don Winslow
blocked me as well oh and Seth Abram
Abramson yeah yeah he blocked me because
I'm a I forget his name I forget his
name but Seth blocked me Don blocked me
um but and and Dan bongino is black
that's really it with Christian I've
kind of you know I just follow along to
see if he has any videos that are crazy
you know most of them Mar and then
decided to say like oh do I have time to
like make a video kind of debunking this
or what have you and so then you get to
this moment where you start seeing these
posts and he's like oh August 25th 2021
my dad is running for Senate Let's go
Team Herschel I'm so proud of you now
whether that was out of pressure from
his father the Republican party what
have you I don't know but doesn't that
seem like in this video because now I I
take anything this [ __ ] [ __ ] says
with a grain of salt yeah but what he
says in the front of this video is that
he was supposed to air this stuff out in
the campaign like he was supposed to
repent type thing yeah and and he said
it didn't happen right and it didn't
happen he said yeah so so I don't know
what was told him what was promised to
him I have no idea my guess is they got
him in a room in Mar-A-Lago promised him
all this stuff so he would go out and
act like he was supporting his dad so
that they he could run on a family
values campaign is famous with him and
this is why Christian here is saying
that all the right wing is mad that he
hasn't been stumping for his dad because
that's what they expected of him that's
what I expect him to do but he's saying
hey all this [ __ ] that you're wanting me
to stunt from is all [ __ ] lies and he
says I don't want to lie to you he's
telling he's telling his social media
following and the world I don't want to
lie anymore it's all a lie about his dad
he'll lie about other things right I'll
get to that but he doesn't want to lie
about his dad anymore and I do and I do
kind of question so like obviously
there's that and then in December he had
this speech that he gave at this
Mar-A-Lago little uh
uh event for you know fundraising for
his father so at that point what he's
claiming right now he's like I did one
event I did one event and I was promised
that he would get out ahead of this so
he announces in August the events in
December he did the event because he was
told his dad would get out ahead of it
and announce this stuff I don't know how
this any of these stories that have come
out help
his candidacy as a U.S senator for the
state of Georgia but that's beyond me
and so you have this right now where
Christian Walker says that he was
promised these things he was promised
that he would get out ahead of it and he
would do this but now we're finding out
that Kristen Walker has had enough right
he he also was in a in a previous video
he he said he said he knew about the
other children
but he couldn't say anything or he
didn't say anything right and so now
he's exposing these lies now whether
this is like you said an off-ramp for
for Maga people or not I don't know
because
as we see right now the right is
attacking him Greg Kelly is the pundit
that he was just referring to in this
video where he's like oh the Greg
Kelly's pull up his posts and he's like
how dare you question my authenticity
and blah blah blah did Greg Kelly steal
it from you
because you're one of the first ones to
bring to social media with this well I
was the first one to compare what he had
posted in I mean other people brought up
other parts he still has tweets up
that's like my dad's running for Senate
and it's his campaign video back in
August right well I mean here's the
thing I I don't I don't think he should
go scrub all that actually I think it's
I think it's good that he leaves it up
so that way we can see what he's
actually talking about because again
it's hard to believe anything that this
[ __ ] says it is hard it is hard for
me to believe anything this [ __ ] says
and and and what makes it easier to
believe is when he's like hey I'm
telling you I supported him because of
this and he really did stop supporting
him publicly there wasn't a lot of
support
um for the last six eight months since
they really since really people started
since he won the Primary right since he
won the primary and he was the candid
and then people started talking about
you know the gun violence and the
[ __ ] just the violence in general the
way he treated his mom the cheating just
just the the other the other children
that he's abandoned I mean this this
stuff started to compound right so you
know I I get that that Christian is
saying hey I wanted him to basically
repent from this and get out in front of
him but he didn't and that was a lie but
it's all lies it's all lies but let's
listen to the video let's listen to the
end of this and then we'll we'll talk
about
um how this is important to Georgia and
the Democracy in general and why this
might just be an off-ramp for Maga let's
listen don't try me don't test my
authenticity all of this has been a lie
and you've known it you've known so
don't you dare
and then to the left he says well he did
all this to your mom and you were still
with them and you know that's weird you
know nothing about my life my parents
went through a dirty divorce I went
through a lot as a child and and you
don't know anything you don't know the
Ebbs and flows of our relationship
nobody knows anything so for everyone
making these wild theories and whatever
that that that's crazy this is about a
bunch of Lies again I could if I had an
issue with whatever I could have ended
this table that's not my intention my
intention is don't lie about your life
at the expense of me my mom and all of
the people that you've affected
throughout your life you don't get to
pretend you're some moral Family Guy you
don't get to pretend all these things
top policy talk normal do not lie very
rich coming from a person who is in
actual support of Ron DeSantis and also
goes on social media and just tells
outright lies like on a daily basis
right um you know again it's really hard
to believe anything he says now
the most important part about this that
I want you to understand with politics
to the audience is that he is burning
down Herschel Walker's campaign right um
this is this is the reason why Herschel
Walker and the Republican Party won a
Christian Walker in herschel's Camp
because they knew this could happen
right they know Herschel Walker's past
they know the facts about him they know
he's toxic they know he will lose if
this stuff gets out and the one thing
that could happen is the social media
king
or whatever you want to call him
Christian Walker because he's the one
who has the social media following he's
the one that people are like what the
crazy ass [ __ ] are you talking about in
a Starbucks drive-through this they knew
this could be a problem and they knew
this would be problematic and they
weren't able to Reign this in all the
way and the reason why is because it's
all [ __ ] lies Christian knows it the
right wing knows it Herschel knows it
the Republican Party knows it and it's
not just Herschel Walker it's Dr Oz he's
a [ __ ] liar all that entire campaign
built on lines
JD Vance oh [ __ ] he was calling Trump
Hitler yeah folks calling Trump Hitler
and the dude has got his Cheeto dust
knee pads on
given the Cheeto dust monster political
fellatio okay it's all [ __ ] lies the
entire Republican party Maga is all
[ __ ] built on the foundation of
fascist lies and Christian is still
supporting this stuff now now here's
what I want to say here's why it's so
important is because Warnock was likely
going to beat Herschel Walker in Georgia
these polls that you're seeing I keep
telling you they're all [ __ ] now if
it makes you feel warm and fuzzy and it
really motivates you to go vote believe
them fine whatever whatever it takes for
you to get motivated to engage in your
democracy do that do that thing now I
will tell you I think Warnock was going
to Stomp the [ __ ]
stop the [ __ ] out of Herschel Walker but
again the person who this morning is
really [ __ ] pissed off I mean I would
imagine that the Kemp campaign and Brian
Kemp is losing their [ __ ] minds this
morning because this is going to affect
turnout in Georgia just and if you don't
believe me go back and look at the
Senate runoff go back and look at it
when Donald Trump interjected himself
with a bunch of nonsense into that
runoff and he lost both those seats for
the Republicans because we got out and
voted and he suppressed their vote this
is what it's gonna happen here folks and
Kemp is [ __ ] pissed off because the
seat that really matters here and again
the senate seat matters Warnock matters
but the seat that really matters in
Georgia for Georgians the most
the most especially when it comes to
accountability for the 2020 election is
that Governor's seat
it's that [ __ ] Governor's seat that
makes the biggest difference for
Georgians to turn it around to show
Georgians that hey you may you may think
you don't like Democrats but let's let a
Democrat run the state who's competent
knows what the [ __ ] they're doing and
we'll show you that hey you you actually
you are a liberal yeah you don't think
you are but you are you just don't know
it and that is that is the difference it
needs to be made and the same goes for
Texas for Florida for Pennsylvania uh
the same goes for all these states where
Democrats have this shot
and Herschel Walker and Christian Walker
the story I believe that especially the
Christian Walker side of the story
because it it became less about him
paying for an abortion because really I
don't give a [ __ ] that he paid for an
abortion I actually I actually think
Herschel Walker probably did the right
thing for that person
Herschel Walker did the right thing by
helping that woman receive a medical
procedure so she didn't have to walk
around and be tied to him for the rest
of her [ __ ] life
because of a bad decision that she
[ __ ] made and that he [ __ ] made
and that that she could just she could
just make sure that she could move on
and make her own choice for her for what
was medically necessary for her and he
did he apparently he paid for it and
that sort of thing I don't begrudge him
for that I don't regret him for that I
don't I don't think that's a bad thing
now the hypocrisy is you know
but here's the thing about the Christian
Walker part of it because really
Christian Walker
overshadowed by him coming out and
saying this is all a bunch of [ __ ]
all of it not just the abortion part the
kid part him being violent he he's not
fit to be a senator is what Christian
Walker is saying and I think the most
important part about this is this this
uh this attitude and this excuse of hey
I'm tired of the lies this might be a
good off-ramp for manga this might be a
good off-ramp for some of your family
members who are believing are acting
like they're believing some of this Q
Anon stuff
um some of this Maga stuff this trumpism
stuff this might give them a sense of an
off ramp here and I think that's a good
thing so I actually I don't believe much
that Christian says and I actually think
what he's doing here is total hypocrisy
by making a video about oh I'm tired of
the lies come on Christian really are
you tired it's just because it's
affecting him personally is the reason
why he's tired of the lies right and
like I said you know uh I don't like
Christian Walker right I have my own
[ __ ] with him uh uh I don't I don't I
don't respect the things that he follows
in the sense of like I don't believe
that we should be taking away people's
rights we should be uh denying uh bodily
autonomy I don't believe that we should
be rejecting those in our community who
are
um who are trans right like his
transphobic homophobic bigoted hatred
towards others does not at all absolve
him like just because of what he did in
coming out and speaking against his
father and Republican party does not at
all absolve him of those sins in which
he was hateful against those people now
if this is him coming to the left and
saying hey I actually had a [ __ ]
wrong the whole time I actually want to
accept the Democratic party then great
we'll take you in we will take you in
and you can be this person who says you
know as an arrest
like I lied uh I was uh this is I I was
in a household in a party that
instilled hatred and hurtful things and
so the only way that I could feel like I
belonged was to only regurgitate those
things onto others right to push them
onto others so that other people white
people whoever whoever would accept me
for for me now whether that's fully
accepting or not to be you know to be
debated but Gabe I I gotta I got a few
Florida guys that I want to get to and I
noticed that we're running out of time
so there's a couple things here that I
want to share with the audience
um to make sure that they know about
these these these Florida men here's one
of them here's a picture I don't know
why he's wearing an Mist I'm not really
sure you know he's supposed to make sure
that Tucker Carlson he he consults with
Tucker Carlson that white boots and
green M M's are not sex you know you're
not supposed to do that anymore you got
to cancel it why was he wearing white
boots number one and number two and I I
don't have time to talk about this I'm
why why don't they have any mud or dirt
on them usually when you wear boots it's
like mud dirt water like there's muck
and there's not I've never I've never uh
I this is the first time seeing uh White
right boots I typically see like a dark
green but these are mud boots these are
not rain boots rain boots are a little
different these are these are [ __ ]
mud boots look I grew up on a farm we
had we had mud boots everywhere and
generally the cheap ones are like black
and they got like a red stripe around
the soul you get you know expensive ones
that are like um you know they're kind
of like camouflage some of them are
warmer they're insulated but this is a
pair of just straight up he's and he's
on the side of the state that had little
to uh no damage as compared to the West
Side wearing these boots it's all again
it's projection look at me I was [ __ ]
Trucking
I was in water that was this tall which
was a puddle right right because
somebody spilled water out of their
bottle right what a [ __ ] loser here's
another Florida guy that I want to get
to um you guys you guys know him he's
another human trafficker speaking of
human traffickers Rhonda sayance is
human trafficker here's here's Mac ants
he's a alleged human trafficker just a
little different but you know they're
all one and the same here he's saying he
wants to abolish
um the Veterans Affairs he wants to
abolish the VA he doesn't like veterans
apparently listen it's really short I
mean why not abolish the VA
huh what
what one more time why not abolish the
VA yeah why not Matt Getz so I would
love to go on about that one too but I
don't think that needs very much
explanation of why that's important
but Gabe there's one thing I want to do
before we leave and I know we're running
out of time huh and I said I said in the
first hour I think the most important
story today that you are not gonna hear
about that you need to pay attention to
that you need to talk about is Justice
katanji Brown Jackson absolutely does a
magnificent job of course she's such a
brilliant human being but she uses their
originalist uh argument on the 14th
Amendment of why this Alabama case of
them trying to take away your right to
vote is absolutely trash
um let's listen to her argument here
um I don't think we can assume that just
because race is taken into account that
that necessarily creates an equal
protection problem because I understood
that we looked at the history and
traditions of the Constitution at what
the framers and the founders thought
about and when I drilled down to that
level of analysis it became clear to me
that the framers themselves adopted the
equal protection Clause the 14th
Amendment the 15th amendment in a
race-conscious way so there she is
that's just a little clip go watch it um
it's on my feed it is a beautiful
beautiful beautiful legal argument
before The Supreme Court and the
questions that she asked to say Hey you
are full of [ __ ] when you say the 14th
amendment was race blind it was done
because of race and you need to
recognize that and she does a beautiful
job this is why this is why it is so
important that you lean into democracy
so that we can actually have focused
people who are qualified and earned
their positions on places like the
Supreme Court like justice katanji Brown
Jackson and I just want to say I am
proud that she's there it was so great
to hear someone with her experience
as a black woman
to be able to speak in a court
about the issue at hand that her
ancestors and she would have been
affected by if she would have been alive
while that 14th amendment was being
drafted and she understands exactly what
that 14th Amendment did and exactly what
the aim was by the framers and the
founders and she absolutely uses
originalist arguments to dunk on these
originalists because they're not
originalists they're not anything
they're they are Herschel Walkers they
are Ronda santises they are [ __ ]
Liars they are frauds they are Fascist
folks thank you for joining us today as
you do every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific right here on the Tony Michaels
podcast don't forget you can go over to
Tony Michaels dot live slash tip you can
give a one-time tip or a set up a
monthly tip that way you can set it and
forget it we appreciate all your support
we run off of it we run off of it some
support you can give us subscribe to the
YouTube channel also go follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels podcast you can
follow mine and Gabe's personal accounts
dude we do a lot of [ __ ] talking over
there also download every single episode
of the Tony Michaels podcast Monday
through Friday on Apple Spotify Google
wherever wherever you hear SpongeBob
games you can follow us on Twitch and
follow us on Facebook even if you're on
the Midas touch Facebook page go over to
at the Tony Michaels follow us over
there on Facebook too you can watch over
there as well maybe fake Gabe will move
over to my page because everyone's like
I don't see them on Facebook they're
watching on my page right and they don't
see the comments and you guys in YouTube
are like where is this fake game he's
over on the Midas touch Facebook page
yeah that's where he's at that's where
that's where that's where the hatred
lives accordingly yeah the super back
page why are you living on the Super PAC
page if you hate Super PAC so much fake
Gabe come on over to my page my page
it's not even named after a super pick
not even a thing not even think so you
can do that you can do that you can do
that buddy come on over and everyone
don't forget to watch every single
weekday same time same place tomorrow oh
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon